oh my gosh he's here I heard he gives
out his cell phone number to everyone on
the team who y'all talking about it's
Caleb Williams whoever wins the
untalented show get some work with him
next year he's a quarterback what am I
going to
play welcome to the GD iron Height's
untalented show remember the worse you
perform the better how do we look
terrible perfect y'all I'll be tap
dancing the gritty to the tune of Mr
Bojangles two hands up two hands back
yes work that terrible
CR if your backup's playing better than
your starter you might have a
quarterback
[Music]
controversy look how fun our culture is
now is this your card no wait don't s me
in half Fam I'm still
recovering hey yo fam not cool St cayb
come to Vegas and I will trade you in
The Patriot
Way I know what check it pish really
good I can't do this anymore please
trade me no you're stuck here forever
watch me once you step out of top dve
stop freestyling you look better than
the
Chiefs you're up next oh we gave our
spot to the Bears
[Music]
unfortunately we will never forget our
domination of the Raider
Tyson no you're too good I going stay in
[Music]
college if you ask your line for a clean
pocket and they start digging for Lent
then you might have a quarterback
controversy it's the horse CER Comedy
Tour I look coach said you already got a
nickname cuz I already know too many Jim
Bob
cooters